Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 46. Ausgabe unserer kleinen Gesprächsreihe. Und ja, es geht weiter in unserem Durchmarsch durch das Sonnensystem und den damit verbundenen Missionen. Und dazu bin ich heute mal wieder nach Darmstadt gefahren, in das ESAG, in das Kontrollzentrum der ESA. Und im Mittelpunkt steht jetzt ein anderer Planet, nämlich die Venus, in diesem Fall aber noch nicht so sehr der Planet selbst, sondern uns interessiert eine Mission, die dorthin geflogen ist, Venus Express. Und um darüber zu sprechen, begrüße ich Jörg Fischer.
Hallo Tim.
Willkommen bei Raumzeit. Ja, was, kurz gesagt, was ist hier deine, was sind deine offizielle Berufsbezeichnung oder Aufgabenbezeichnung hier eigentlich?
Okay, auf Englisch wäre es Spacecraft Operations Engineer. Das heißt, wir sind dafür da, alle Sateliten, alle Wissenschaftssatelliten, die die ESA betreut, zu steuern.
Das heißt, du bist mit in dem Team, die die Mission ganz konkret die ganze Zeit steuert, überwacht und quasi mitfliegt, auch wenn er nicht an Bord sitzt. Was hat dich denn, was hat dich denn so zur ESOC gebracht? Wie bist du denn, auf welchem Weg bist du denn an diesem Posten gelandet?
Also es klingt ein bisschen komisch, aber das kam damals, 1969, mit der Mondlandung. Das habe ich gerade so als kleines Kind noch mitgekriegt, die ersten Bilder am Fernsehen. Und seitdem war meine Faszination für Raumfahrt eigentlich erwacht.
Das hat aber echt keinen kalt gelassen, der das irgendwie so mitbekommen hat.
Es gibt zwar viele, die heute noch anzweifeln, ob die tatsächlich da gewesen sind, aber ich sage, sie waren.
Du hast ja gesehen, Bayer am Fernsehen, muss man sein.
Genau. Dann bin ich nach der Schule nach Braunschweig auf die Universität gegangen und habe Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik studiert. Das war für mich schon vorgezeichnet sozusagen.
Okay, einfach durchmarschiert.
Und ich bin dann direkt nach der Universität den ersten Job gleich hier angenommen und bin immer noch da.
Super, also du bist ja sozusagen schon fast Veteran.
Ich bin fast schon Veteran oder Dinosaurier, wie manche uns nennen, die hier mehr als drei bis fünf Jahre arbeiten. Ich bin jetzt in meinem 22.
Jahr. Oha, okay, alles klar. Also du hast schon einiges gesehen und mitleiden dürfen und mitfreuen dürfen. Was hat das umfasst? Mit welchen Missionen bist du da auf dem Weg so betraut gewesen?
Also angefangen hat das Ganze 1990 mit der Mission Hipparchus. Das war damals ein Satellit, der sozusagen die Sterne vermessen hat in hoher Genauigkeit. Als das Ding dann seinen Auftrag erfüllt hatte und nicht mehr funktionierte, bin ich rübergewechselt zu Cluster. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das ein Begriff ist. Das sind die vier Satelliten, die im Moment um die Erde rumfliegen, um das Magnetfeld der Erde zu vermessen. Das ist allerdings Cluster 2. Ich habe damals auf Cluster 1 schon gearbeitet. Die Satelliten sind ja leider beim allerersten Flug der Ariane 5, 38 Sekunden nach dem Start, explodiert und in den Sumpf gefallen. Deshalb dann auch noch die Mission Cluster 2, die ich auch noch mit vorbereitet habe und auch in den Orbit gebracht habe. Dann habe ich den Sprung zu den interplanetaren Missionen gemacht. Erst Mars Express habe ich gemacht seit 2001 bis ungefähr 2007 und dann bin ich gewechselt auf Venus Express.
Das heißt, bei Venus Express warst du dann auch von Anfang an dabei?
Nein, der bin ich erst dazu gestoßen. Die sind ja 2005 im November gestartet und ich bin 2007 erst dazu gestoßen, weil einer der Ingenieure heute gegangen ist und die braucht einen Ersatz.
Ah, okay, das heißt, das Lager gewechselt. Aber trotzdem kriegt man ja auch gerade jetzt hier am Standort doch auch von den Schwester-Missionen immer eine Menge mit, oder? Das bleibt jetzt nicht raus.
Natürlich, wenn jeder irgendeinen Satellitheber der ESA ein Problem hat, dann wissen das sofort alle.
Aber nicht nur, wenn es ein Problem gibt.
Nein, nein, wir kommen auch mit, wenn neue Starts sind und fiebern natürlich auch immer mit, mit den Jungs, die im Kontrollraum sitzen, dass auch alles funktioniert.
Aber es gibt ja auch eine ganze Menge Ähnlichkeiten zwischen diesen Missionen. Ich denke, dass es da auch einen regen wissenschaftlichen, technischen...
Den großen Unterschied gibt es halt zwischen den erdbeobachtenden Missionen und den interplanetaren Missionen. Allein die Art der Steuerung für diese Satelliten ist ganz anders. Weil man muss mit einer Zeitkonstante noch mitrechnen, weil die Signale natürlich, je weiter man weg ist von der Erde, immer länger brauchen, um zu den Satelliten zu kommen, um man die Antwort dann auch wieder zurückkriegt. Das ist ein ganz großer Unterschied zwischen den Erdbeobachtern und den Interplanetaren.
Aber so die Interplanetaren unter sich, in dem Club, da...
Bei uns, bei der Isopir...
Die ist nicht so groß, also Venus Express zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du gewechselt bist, nicht komplett fremd?
Nein, nein, weil die Interplanetaren, die wir im Moment haben, also Mars Express, Venus Express und Rosetta, die sind im Prinzip nicht hundert Prozent baugleich, aber entstammen aus der gleichen Familie sozusagen.
Also auch auf derselben Technik-Generation, was Computer auch betrifft, etc.
Und Mars Express und Venus Express sind sogar echte Schwester-Schiffe. Venus Express ist sozusagen nach den Blaupausen von Mars Express gebaut worden, sieht ähnlich aus, hat natürlich nur eine andere Anpassung, weil das zu Venus geht und nicht zu Mars. Aber im Prinzip ist Software, Hardware sehr, sehr ähnlich und dadurch können wir auch missionsübergreifend helfen, wenn es irgendwo Probleme gibt.
Also abgesehen jetzt von dem offensichtlichen Kostensparen, was halt nicht neu gemacht werden muss, hat es vor allem auch diesen Teamvorteil, sodass man auch mal eben das Team wechseln kann.
Richtig, so wie ich es gemacht habe zwischen Mars Express und Venus Express.
Ja, trotzdem, auch wenn du jetzt nicht unmittelbar dabei warst, würde mich natürlich interessieren, ob du was dazu sagen kannst oder nicht. Es ist ja immer so eine Sache, wenn solche Missionen beschlossen werden sollen, muss ja zunächst einmal auch ein strong case gemacht werden. Man muss ja auch darlegen, warum das und nicht irgendetwas anderes. Die beiden Missionen scheinen ja auch in der Hinsicht verbunden zu sein. Also ist das so, dass die auch beide quasi schon parallel ausgedacht wurden oder war das nur klar, man macht jetzt mal Mars und oh, das hat aber ganz gut geklappt, dann können wir ja auch gleich nochmal zu Venus fliegen oder war das so von vornherein auch schon so konzipiert, dass man sagt, naja, die sind beide gleich weg, nur in die andere Richtung, da könnte man doch gleich mal voll auswählen.
Nee, direkt war das nicht so. Also man hat erst mal abgewartet mit Mars Express, wie das Ganze so funktioniert und ist dann sehr schnell drauf übergegangen, auch noch Venus Express zu machen, zumal man diesen Kosten- und Zeitvorteil halt hat, weil der selbe Satellit im Prinzip zweimal verwendet wird. Das ist fast schon wie so eine Art Fließlandproduktion. Aber ursprünglich geplant war, irgendwann mal zu Venus zu fliegen, aber die Idee, wir könnten ja eigentlich das, was wir jetzt schon gemacht haben, gleich weiterverwenden, indem wir fast dieselben Instrumente nehmen und so weiter und so fort, ein bisschen anpassen und den dann andersrum schicken. Und Mars Express war damals schon als sozusagen eine Express-Flexi-Mission relativ schnell und kostengünstig gebaut worden. Das hat sich dann bei Venus Express noch mal erhöht. Also da war noch weniger Zeit. Aber die hatten wie gesagt schon die Blaupausen da, die Prozessoren, alles war schon da. Dann haben sie das schnell wieder zusammengebaut und dann halt in relativ kurzer Zeit die Mission beschlossen, abgesegnet, vorbereitet und ausgeschossen.
Das ist ja immer gut, wenn man sagen kann, okay, wir wollen zwar eine komplett neue Mission machen, aber eigentlich ist schon alles erfunden. Wir müssen es nur noch anpassen. Das ist ja eine ganz andere Nummer, als wenn man jetzt sagt, ja, hier mal Uranus und so, das mal nachdenken. Das geht natürlich nicht so schnell von der Hand. Das heißt, im Vergleich zu anderen Missionen ging es dann auch relativ schnell und unkompliziert? Oder ist das jetzt auch ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert?
Die Missionsvorbereitung ist sehr ähnlich. Man muss sozusagen, der Satellit wird von dem Prime-Contractor sozusagen gebaut und der gibt eigentlich Vorgaben für die Prozeduren, die wir entwickeln müssen, um den Satelliten zu steuern. Das sind also erstmal, sag ich mal, die Tätigkeiten, wo man erstmal nur mit Papier arbeitet oder mit dem Computer und eigentlich noch gar nicht direkt mit dem Satelliten. Da bereitet man Dinge vor und das ist bei Mars Express und Venus Express ähnlich gewesen. Dafür braucht man ungefähr so drei Jahre, sag ich mal.
Warum zu Venus? Was will man da?
Die Venus ist eigentlich der erdähnlichste Planet in unserem Sonnensystem und er ist auch im Sonnensystemmaßstab fast in der gleichen Position wie die Erde. Die Venus ist ein paar Kilometer näher dran an der Sonne, aber im Prinzip ist die Venus selbst auch noch eine Million Kilometer von der Sonne entfernt. Was sehr interessant ist, ist, dass die Venus offensichtlich einen wahnsinnigen Treibhauseffekt irgendwann mal gestartet hat. Und das ist halt sehr interessant im puncto Erde, weil wir sprechen heutzutage sehr viel über den Treibhauseffekt, der unser Klima verändert hier auf der Erde. Und da hat man sozusagen den Worst Case, wo wirklich über wahrscheinlich Millionen Jahre sich dieser Treibhauseffekt hochgeschaukelt hat und die jetzt halt komplett 400 Grad unten auf der Oberfläche haben, nur komplett mit Wolken bedeckt sind, die die Hitze nicht rauslassen. Und da stehen wir mit der Erde wahrscheinlich gerade so ein bisschen am Anfang. Und diese Prozesse zu verstehen, das ist eigentlich so das Hauptinteresse der Wissenschaftler. Dafür wird die Atmosphäre untersucht, in diversen Wellenlängen wird sie gescannt, um herauszufinden, warum ist das auf der Venus passiert? Hat die Venus vielleicht früher auch mal erdähnliche Züge gehabt? War da vielleicht mal Wasser? Das sind alles Dinge, die man rausfinden möchte, um es sozusagen zu verstehen, was auf der Erde passiert.
Die beiden Nachbarn sind sehr interessant. Beide haben sozusagen ein Schicksal erlitten, was man nicht haben will. Beim Mars ist es eher der Mangel der Atmosphäre und bei der Venus gibt es eigentlich zu viel davon.
Die Dichte der Atmosphäre ist ungefähr 100 Mal höher als hier bei uns auf der Erde.
Was gab es denn bereits für Missionen vorher, die sich mit der Venus beschäftigt haben?
Interessanterweise sind die Russen eigentlich die, die sich am meisten mit der Venus beschäftigt haben. Die haben auch schon diverse Landegeräte in den letzten 40, 50 Jahren mal hochgeschickt, waren aber leider nicht allzu erfolgreich. Die haben meistens nur so 30 Minuten oder mal ein paar, ein Viertelstunde überlebt durch dieses wirklich starke, wie soll man sagen, durch die Hitze und die Art der Atmosphäre, die säurerhaltig ist und so weiter, hat das die Dinge relativ schnell zerlegt. Die Amerikaner sind mit Satelliten um den Venus geflogen und haben auch mal Satelliten in die Umlaufbahn gebracht. Da sind aber keinerlei dauerhaften Untersuchungen gemacht worden, wie wir das jetzt mit Venus Express haben, der im stabilen Orbit um die Venus rumfliegt, jetzt schon seit 2006, April 2006.
Das heißt, die waren nur sehr kurz da, weil die nicht länger gehalten haben?
Genau, die haben also teilweise einfach nur mal versucht, da überhaupt erst mal hinzukommen. Es ist auch gar nicht so einfach, von der Erde aus alles so zu berechnen, dass das wunderbar funktioniert, wenn man genau an dem Punkt rauskommt, wo man hin möchte. Weil die Planeten bewegen sich, die Venus bewegt sich relativ zur Erde und relativ zur Sonne. Also die Berechnungen, die unsere Flugdynamiker anstellen müssen, sind schon recht kompliziert.
Ja, das hatten wir ja auch schon in der frühen Folge zur Missionsanalyse, in dem Fall auch konkret am Beispiel von Mars Express auch schon mal dargelegt. Es kam jetzt auch noch mal besonders zur Sprache in der Folge für die Mercure-Mission, also Bipi-Colombo, wo schnell deutlich wurde, dass wenn jetzt so ein Objekt so nah an der Sonne dran ist, dass es mal noch mal extra unbequem ist. Weil dann natürlich einfach die Sonne da mit ihrer Gravitation einem die ganze Zeit dazwischenpusht. In der Hinsicht ist aber die Venus vergleichsweise einfach zu erreichen, oder?
Richtig, also wir brauchten keinerlei Besuche bei anderen Planeten, um Geschwindigkeit aufzunehmen. Die Rakete ist gestartet und dann auf den Weg geschickt worden, direkt zur Venus und direkt in das Venus-Orbit eingeschossen.
Aber da muss man dann schon auch das richtige Launchfenster erwischen. Also man kann nicht irgendwann mal starten, sondern die Venus muss auch gerade so vorbeikommen, weil sie auf der anderen Seite der Sonne ist, dann ist man nicht so gut. Okay, da können wir ja gleich nochmal drüber sprechen. Mich würde jetzt nochmal die Vorbereitung interessieren. Also ist ja schon klar geworden, man hat sich sehr an Mars Express orientiert. Was wollte man denn jetzt dieser Mission mit auf den Weg geben? Was ist denn nun wirklich zusammengebaut worden? Woraus besteht Venus Express?
Venus Express, der Corpus von Venus Express, ist im Prinzip eins zu eins übernommen worden von Mars Express. Änderungen gab es zum Beispiel in der Außenhaut, weil wir sehr viel näher ran sind an der Sonne. Deshalb muss mehr reflektierende Folie aufgebracht werden außen. Statt wie bei Mars Express schwarz, weil weit weg von der Sonne, da muss möglichst noch ein bisschen Sonnenenergie aufnehmen, damit er nicht zu kalt wird. Dadurch, dass wir sehr viel näher mit Venus Express an der Sonne dran sind, braucht man auch andere und weniger Solarzellen, um Energie zu erzeugen. Das heißt, die eigentlichen Sonnenpaneele sind kleiner bei Venus Express und haben auch noch Reflektoren drauf. Also es wird nicht mal alles Sonnenlicht, was wirklich aufprallt, auch an Energie genutzt.
Man hätte sozusagen einen Energieüberschuss.
Genau, haben wir sowieso, aber das ist ja auch gewollt, damit man später mal nicht irgendwo in Probleme kommt.
Aber das ist auch dann die primäre und einzige Energiequelle?
Jawohl, es wird rein nur Solartechnik. Batterien sind natürlich dabei für die Fälle, wo Venus Express hinter der Venus verschwindet.
Im Schatten halt.
Genau, im Schatten und da brauchst du natürlich Batterien. Aber nein, Atomreaktoren oder sowas wie jetzt bei dem Mars-Landegerät, die braucht man da nicht.
Okay, und was ist drin?
Was ist drin? Man braucht keine optische Kamera im Prinzip, eine hochauflösende, so wie Mars Express, dadurch, dass eigentlich nur Wolken zu sehen sind. Das heißt also die Kamera für optische Aufnahmen ist relativ simpel im Vergleich zu der Mars Express. Aber es gibt eine. Es gibt eine, damit man auch die Wolkenformationen dann auch sehen kann. Der Großteil der Instrumente arbeitet allerdings in einem anderen Frequenzbereich einfach. Die machen halt auch Bilder, aber dann halt eher im Infrarotbereich, in anderen Wellenlängen. Man kann durch die Wolkendecke mit bestimmten Wellenlängen auch durchgucken, um dann am Boden Temperaturen und sowas zu messen. Aber die Atmosphäre wird einfach mit mehreren Instrumenten, unterschiedlichen Instrumenten in unterschiedlichen Frequenzbereichen bearbeitet, um die Komposition herauszufinden.
Also Spektrometer ohne Ende.
Und gleichzeitig hat die Venus ja auch eine sogenannte Superrotation der Atmosphäre. Das heißt, die Atmosphäre bewegt sich wesentlich schneller um die Venus, als die Venus sich eigentlich dreht. Das heißt, es gibt wahnsinnige Stürme von sehr hoher Geschwindigkeit. Und auch das zu verstehen, die hat zum Beispiel zwei Wirbel am Südpol, die schon seit, so ähnlich wie der rote Fleck beim Jupiter schon seit Jahrmillionen ein doppeltes Sturmsystem bilden, die aber genau über dem Südpol liegen. Und diese ganze atmosphärische Bewegung zu analysieren und zu verstehen, warum das so ist, ist auch ein weiterer Auftrag sozusagen der Wissenschaft.
So eine super Atmosphäre ist das, wo alles ins totale Extrem umgeschlagen ist und wo man dann wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut ablesen kann, wie es sich maximal entwickeln könnte. Also, welche Instrumente kommen da jetzt ins Spiel?
Wir haben Instrumente, wie gesagt, die meisten sind Kameras, aber in bestimmten Wellenlängen. Optisches Instrument hatten wir schon, die anderen Instrumente, bei Mars Express war auch noch ein Radar dabei, das ist leider auf Venus Express nicht mehr mit eingebaut worden. Das war wahrscheinlich zeitlich zu kurz, das so umzubauen und anders zu machen, dass man da die gleichen Effekte noch gehabt hätte. Man benutzt interessanterweise bei Venus Express sowie auch bei Mars Express auch einfach die normale Kommunikationsantenne, wenn man die Antenne auf die Erde ausgerichtet hat, aber dann so langsam hinter der Venus verschwindet, kann man dadurch, dass das Signal durch die Atmosphäre durchgeht, auch die Komposition der Atmosphäre selber entwickeln. Nur dadurch, dass man sieht, wie sich das Kommunikationssignal verschiebt.
Ohne, dass die Antenne jetzt da besonders höher gebaut worden ist.
Es ist kein Instrument, aber es gibt auch dafür einen Wissenschaftler, der sozusagen die Hauptantenne für seine Versuche benutzt.
Immer bei Satellitenuntergang sozusagen. Okay, also das meiste ist optisch, beziehungsweise andere Frequenzbereiche, die gemessen werden.
Ja, wir hatten auch ein sogenanntes Fourier-Spektrometer an Bord, das allerdings leider nie funktioniert hat. Das ist damals schon kurz nach dem Start ausprobiert worden. Man hat festgestellt, dass aus irgendeinem Grund dieses Instrument nicht funktioniert.
Was hätte denn das machen sollen?
Das hätte bestimmte Moleküle in der Atmosphäre finden können. Also zum Beispiel Methan, Sauerstoff, Kohlendioxid, Kohlemonoxid, alles was da drin ist, hätte man direkt die Mengenverteilung halt sehen können. Das ist auch wieder eine bestimmte Wellenlänge, mit der man sozusagen die Atmosphäre scannt. Und das fällt jetzt leider weg. Die anderen Instrumente haben andere Aufgaben, aber dieser eine Bereich, wo wir für dieses PFS wie es hieß, konnte nur leider nicht bearbeitet werden, aber wir haben trotzdem einen hohen Erfolg dieser Mission inzwischen.
Wie redundant sind solche Instrumente üblicherweise ausgelegt?
Das eigentliche Instrument meistens nur einmal. Aber interne Komponenten sind meistens doppelt ausgelegt. Das heißt, man hat zwei kleine Prozessoren sozusagen, zwei Speicher und so weiter, zwei unterschiedliche Stromversorgungen, falls diese Dinge ausfallen. Aber die eigentliche Optik ist meistens nur einmal vorhanden.
Ja, und hat man denn herausgefunden, was nicht funktioniert hat an dem Instrument?
Nein. Leider nicht. Es hat viele Versuche gegeben am Anfang noch, um irgendwie dieses Instrument noch in Gang zu kriegen. Aber so ganz genau weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, was die dabei entwickelt haben oder herausgefunden haben, weil das war zu einer Zeit, als ich noch nicht bei Venus Express bearbeitet habe.
Das war dann sozusagen direkt am Start. Und dann wusste man schon, nach dem ersten Testen wird nichts. Das ist natürlich immer sehr schade. Da hängen ja auch viele Herzen dran, Leute, die das auch gebaut haben und sich jahrelang darauf gefreut haben, die Daten auswerten zu können.
Selbst wenn das ein Instrument war, was baugleich auch auf Mars Express war, ist es doch schade für die Wissenschaftler, diese Möglichkeit sozusagen verpasst zu haben, da noch bestimmte Extra-Dinge über die Venus herauszufinden.
Aber manchmal ist es ja auch so, dass man dann andere Instrumente unter Umständen noch so ein bisschen, auf ursprünglich nicht geplante Art und Weise mitnutzt, um dann solche Sachen auch noch rauszuschälen.
Ja, wobei die eigentlich schon sehr spezifisch eingestellt sind, die Instrumente. Man darf die Dinge auch nicht überkompliziert machen, weil je komplizierter ein Instrument ist, umso schwerer ist es zu beherrschen. Umso schwerer sind halt auch Fehler auszumerzen. Also es muss schon relativ einfach aufgebaut sein, um auch mögliche Fehlerquellen einfach auszuschließen.
So, jetzt haben wir aber bestimmt noch nicht alles durch, oder? Von den Instrumenten.
Von den Instrumenten.
Was ist so mit Gravitation? Wird die gemessen?
Na, Gravitation nicht. Da haben wir zwar ein Kreiselsystem, wo auch Beschleunigungsmesser da sind, aber die werden eigentlich nur für die eigentliche Satellitenkontrolle benutzt. Wir haben noch ein Gerät, was die Magnetosphäre der Venus aufzeichnet und einen Überblick gibt im globalen Sinn, wie das Magnetfeld der Venus überhaupt verteilt ist. Es ist nicht so stark wie das Erdmagnetfeld. Da haben sie schon viel rausgefunden. Es ist auch das einzige Instrument, das die ganze Zeit über immer an ist. Die anderen werden zwischendurch auch mal abgeschaltet. Aber das ist ein System, das die ganze Zeit immer nur läuft und permanent Daten liefert.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ist eigentlich Venus Express ein Universal-Satellit zur Planeten-Erkundung. Es geht darum, möglichst viel allgemeine Daten, die eben auch über eine längere Zeit zu gewinnen, um einfach erst mal ein Bild zu haben. Einerseits um direkt natürlich Erkenntnisse zu machen, aber es ist auch so ein potenzieller Vorbereiter für spezialisiertere Missionen. Dass man dann irgendwann sieht, alles klar, da scheint es einen interessanten Bereich zu geben, den müsste man sich mal genauer anschauen. Aber um das zu machen, bräuchte man dann auch die entsprechenden Instrumente.
Man hat immer eine Mission, die was rausfindet. Die nächste Mission baut darauf auf, geht weiter in die Tiefe und dann wieder die nächste Mission. Wenn die gestartet werden, werden immer, so wie man es bei Mars aussieht, da fliegt ja jedes Jahr einer hin. Sämtliche Erfahrungen aus den ersten Missionen werden mit dem neuen verbunden.
Aber außer dem Vorgänger Mars Express war die Informationsdichte noch nicht so groß bei der Venus.
Ja, dadurch, dass man nicht so schicke Fotos machen kann wie auf dem Mars mit der 3D-Kamera, ist es für die Öffentlichkeit auch nicht ganz so super interessant wie alles, was Mars Express liefert. Mars hat einen sehr hohen Stellenwert, allein auch durch die NASA, die schon so viele Missionen gestartet hat, die ja auch in Public Relations sehr offen ist, die wirklich alles immer verteilen. Da weiß die ganze Welt im Prinzip, Mars, oh toll, und da fährt ein Rover rum, oh wow, und Satelliten usw. Bei der Venus sieht das ein bisschen anders aus. Da denke ich mal, dass der Mars Express einen gewissen Vorteil in Richtung Public Relations hat, dass sich die Leute da sehr interessieren. Bei der Venus ist das halt noch etwas reduziert.
Also ein Rover auf der Venus herumfahren zu lassen, wäre auch mal ganz pfiffig.
Das wäre pfiffig und eine sehr große Herausforderung. Weil in dem Umfeld da ein Rover zu betreiben, das wäre äußerst schwierig. Allein durch die hohen Temperaturen und die sehr aggressive Atmosphäre. Wie gesagt, von den Russen haben die vielen Landegeräte meistens nicht sehr lange überlebt.
Vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen zurück zu dem eigentlichen Zeitstrahl dieser Mission. Wann begann Venus Express dann konkret in Planung zu gehen?
Im Planung war 2002, 2003 ungefähr fing die Planung an.
Also jetzt knapp zehn Jahre her.
Genau. Und gestartet wurde sie im November 2005 von Baikonur mit einer Soyuz-Rakete. Fünf Monate hat es gedauert.
Das heißt, man hat drei Jahre vorher mit der Planung begonnen und dann war schon der Start?
Richtig.
Also da ist ja der Name Express...
Daher der Name Express noch mehr als bei Mars Express.
Ist das der Grund, dass das so genannt wurde?
Ja, und zwar war das sozusagen der Start, sollte es eine Serie werden von schnell durchzuführenden Missionen durch eine hohe Wiederverwendung einzelner Anteile dieser Mission. Und das hat auch sehr gut geklappt. Selbst Rosetta ist zwar ein wesentlich größerer Satellit und hat auch noch ganz andere Instrumente und so was dabei. Aber zumindest der Grundaufbau des Satelliten, die Grundsoftware, die drauf ist, läuft auch in abgewandelter Form auf Mars Express und Venus Express. Das heißt, man hat einen großen Zeit- und Kostenfaktor. Es geht alles wesentlich schneller, wenn man die gleiche Software wieder verwenden kann. Und es geht wesentlich schneller, wenn der Großteil der Hardware ähnlich ist.
Ja, klar. Aber drei Jahre ist ja wirklich für eine Raumfahrtmission...
Sehr schnell, ja.
Wir haben hier schon einiges besprochen, aber so unter acht Jahren könnte ich mich gar nicht erinnern, dass da überhaupt irgendwas stattgefunden hat. War einem das gleich von Anfang an, also war das von vornherein klar, dass man das in einem kurzen Zeitraum auch schafft? Da muss man ja im Prinzip gleich mit der Reservierung des Startplatzes beginnen. Das ist ja fast das erste, was man macht.
Die Wissenschaftler haben sich natürlich schon vorher damit beschäftigt. Wie kommen wir mal zur Venus wieder? Und das war halt recht attraktiv, weil Mars Express selbst auch in kurzer Zeit, sage ich mal in Anführungsstrichen, im Vergleich zu anderen Missionen entwickelt wurde. Und da man schon gesehen hat, wenn man so viele Sachen weiter verwenden kann, dann kann man die Zeitdauer, die es braucht, um die Mission wirklich zu entwickeln, um einiges verkürzen. Man kann zum Beispiel die Instrumente, die auf dem Mars Express laufen, sind zum großen Teil dieselben, die wir auf Venus Express verwenden, sowie von Rosetta Instrumente, die auch auf Venus Express laufen. Also es ist sozusagen eine ganze Familie von Instrumenten, die für die interplanetaren Missionen entwickelt wurden, die man sozusagen blockweise wieder auf die anderen Satelliten verteilen konnte.
Die dann nur für den jeweiligen spezifischen Anbindungsfall und die Bedingungen, je nachdem, wo man sich befindet, wie nah an der Sonne man dran ist, angepasst werden müssen.
Und selbst die Missionsvorbereitung, die man bei Mars Express und Rosetta gemacht hat, die Prozedurenentwicklung ist sehr, sehr ähnlich für Venus Express. Das heißt, wir haben für Venus Express 70, 80 Prozent der Prozeduren von Mars Express übernommen und nur ganz leicht angepasst.
Also was jetzt den Anflug betrifft?
Den Anflug natürlich nicht, aber die reine Kontrolle des Satelliten, die Bedienung des Satelliten, die ist sozusagen das User Manual von dem einen auf den anderen wieder draufgepackt.
Also die ganze Telekommando, wie man mit dem Ding redet etc.
Und da spart man natürlich eine ganze Menge Zeit, als wenn man das alles neu entwickeln müsste.
Trotzdem, man musste jetzt eine Flugbahn dafür auch finden. Du sagst, man hat sich damit grundsätzlich schon mal beschäftigt. Also man wusste, kann so schwer nicht sein, sag ich jetzt mal. Zumindest ist es klar, dass die Grundlagen dafür vorhanden sind. Das ist jetzt eben nur eine spezifische Ausrede. Wie schnell ist dann dieser Flugweg ausgerechnet worden? Also wie lange hat das gedauert?
Das kann ich dir so nicht beantworten.
Aber lang kann es ja nicht gedauert haben. In dem Moment, wo man sagt, wir wollen jetzt auch wirklich drei Jahre vorher sich den Slot auf der Rakete zu sichern, heißt ja, man muss auch schon mal in etwa wissen, wann man überhaupt losfliegen kann.
Richtig. Und wo man hin will und was für ein Orbit man auf der Venus haben will. Das ist ganz entscheidend dafür, wo du dann in das Orbit einschießt. Und diese Überlegungen müssen selbstverständlich vorher gemacht werden. Und dann kann man, im Prinzip sind es alles Naturgesetze. Also die Bewegung, die relative Bewegung von Venus zur Erde, das lässt sich alles berechnen, ist ja konstant. Und dann kann man im Prinzip auch von der Gravitation her rechnen, wie sieht die Flugkurve aus, wenn wir an welchem Punkt sozusagen den Erdorbit verlassen. Das ist da, wo die Oberstufe der Rakete dann im Prinzip den entscheidenden Push gibt in Richtung Venus.
Die Venus bewegt sich ja ungefähr so, hat so ein Zweidrittel der Jahreslänge, ist also etwas schneller unterwegs, sprich holt die Erde eigentlich die ganze Zeit immer wieder ein. Das heißt, jetzt mal salopp formuliert, man muss eigentlich nur warten, bis die Venus davon geschossen ist, auf der anderen Seite wieder um die Sonne herumkommt und quasi drauf und dran ist, einen wieder einzuholen und in dem Moment, im richtigen Moment, schießt man Rakete los, fliegt mehr oder weniger gerade direkt auf den Punkt zu, den sie dann nach dieser Flugreise erreicht hat und dann lässt man sich von der Venus wieder einfangen.
Dazu muss man den Satelliten abbremsen, damit er auch von der Gravitation des Planeten eingefangen werden kann.
Das heißt, muss entsprechende Bremssysteme auch haben. Man bremst jetzt nicht durch andere Tricks, dass man noch mal irgendwo vorbeifliegt.
Das ist ein Hauptmotor, sowohl bei Mars Express als auch Venus Express, der dann eine bestimmte Anzahl von Minuten feuert. Und das den Satelliten so weit abbremst, dass die Gravitation des Planeten den Planeten einfängt. In eine erste Umlaufbahn. Danach muss sie natürlich noch angepasst werden. Aber der Einschuss als solches ist sozusagen ein einmaliger Versuch. Wenn man da den verpasst, dann fliegt man dran vorbei. Und dann kann man nur hoffen, dass man irgendwo auf dieser großen Ellipse zurückkommt. Und vielleicht die Möglichkeit hat, noch mal einen Einschuss zu machen. Die Japaner haben das letztlich auch mit Mars erlebt. Die hatten ihre Mission zum Mars geschickt. Und haben den Einschuss verpasst. Jetzt haben sie die Mission so umgeformt, dass er in fünf Jahren wieder in die Nähe des Mars kommt. Und dann werden sie noch mal versuchen, einen Einschuss zu machen, sofern sie noch genug Sprit haben. Diese Möglichkeit besteht. Aber im Prinzip, wenn man das verpasst hat, das war's.
Ist so eine Mission vorbereitet, dass man solche Hibernation... Ich nehme mal an, ein stabiler Flug, so ähnlich wie bei Rosetta. Dass man sagt, ab jetzt nur noch reisen, jetzt rotieren wir ein bisschen und fliegen blind durchs All. Und wachen irgendwann wieder auf.
Das wird aber nicht vorher schon mit einbezogen in die Überlegung.
Aber die Systeme sind so flexibel, dass man das programmieren kann?
Die Systeme sind so flexibel, dass man das programmieren kann. Das ist wahr, ja. Aber im Prinzip muss man trotzdem überlegen, man muss ja immer noch Sprit verbrauchen, um die Flugbahn anzupassen, dass man irgendwann auch wieder zu den Planeten der Wahl zurückkehrt. Die Frage ist, ob man dann am Ende wirklich noch genug Sprit hat, um den eigentlichen Einschuss zu machen. Aber wahrscheinlich, wenn es gerade geht, wird es auch ein anderes Orbit, als man es ursprünglich mal vorgesehen hat.
Aber der Spritbedarf ist schon nicht ohne.
Wir verbrennen 80 Prozent des Sprits nur für den Einschuss um den Planeten.
Und der Rest ist Reserve?
Der Rest ist Reserve und für Orbit und Kontrollmanöver im Prinzip zum Ausgleichen.
Wie lange war dann... also Start?
Da war November 2005 und April 2006 sind wir an der Venus angekommen.
Das heißt, das hat gerade mal so fünf Monate gedauert? Also man ist auch sehr viel schneller da, als man jetzt beim Mars ist.
Ungefähr zwei Monate.
Und dann ist diese Brems... Also womit wurde gestartet?
Mit der Sojus-Rakete.
Der Sojus von Baikonur aus.
Die hatte eine Oberstufe, die hieß Fregat. Diese Oberstufe hat im Prinzip den entscheidenden Push gegeben Richtung Venus und hat sich dann abgeklinkt. Das heißt, Venus Express ist nicht mit dem eigenen Motor sozusagen.
Na ja, okay, also mit der Sojus erst mal...
So viel Skrutt hätte man da gar nicht mitnehmen können, wenn wir das auch noch mit hätten selbst machen müssen.
Was ist das vielleicht nochmal interessant, diese Launchphase, weil da unterscheiden sich ja die Missionen dann auch immer. Das heißt, die Sojus-Rakete hat jetzt erst mal die Schwerarbeit geleistet und einen so weit in den Erd... Ist das dann auch ein Erd-Orbit, der dann erst mal erarbeitet?
Das ist zunächst mal ein Erd-Orbit, genau. Und dann wartet man auf dem Erd-Orbit ab, bis man genau den Punkt erreicht hat, von wo aus man zur Venus schießen muss. Und dann aktiviert der Motor...
Dann gibt es noch einen zweiten Start.
Das ist auch sehr wichtig, weil ohne diesen Push würde der Satellit niemals die Venus erreichen. Das heißt, wenn diese Oberstufe von der Soyuz nicht funktioniert, dann hätte man im günstigsten Fall noch einen Erdbeobachtungssatelliten. Wenn man Pech hat, kommt er gleich wieder runter.
Und wie schnell muss man dann werden? Ist das die maximal erzielbare Geschwindigkeit? Oder ist es jetzt gar nicht so wichtig, dass man super schnell unterwegs ist?
Nein, aber man muss eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit haben, um der Gravitation der Erde zu entfliehen. Das nennt sich Fluchtgeschwindigkeit. Das ist eine feste Größe, die berechnet ist auf der Gravitationsbasis der Erde. Und diese Geschwindigkeit muss erreicht werden. Sonst kann man den Erdorbit nicht verlassen.
Und das reicht dann auch schon? Mehr braucht man nicht? Hauptsache, man ist mal geflohen? Oder muss man darüber hinaus auch noch sehr viel beschleunigen?
Nein, die kriegen eine Endgeschwindigkeit im Prinzip von der Fregatte mitgegeben. Was dann gemacht wird, nur noch an Manövern, bis man da ist, sind kleinere Anpassungsmanöver, damit das Zielfenster möglichst genau getroffen wird.
Meine Frage war, ist diese Mindestfluchtgeschwindigkeit schon ausreichend, also die, die man braucht um die Erde zu fahren, ist das schon ausreichend, um dann bis zu Venus zu kommen? Man muss jetzt nicht darüber hinaus noch sehr viel mehr Speed aufnehmen, weil das einfach schon schnell genug ist.
Es ist auch mit den chemischen Antrieben, die haben eine bestimmte Maximumgröße, die sie erreichen können. Dann ist der Sprit verbraucht und dann war's das. Der Rest ist einfach träge Masse im gravitationsfreien Raum.
Das heißt, dieser zweite Start aus dem Orbit ist dann auch noch mal so ein Ruhemoment. Es ist ja bei allen Missionen so, in dem Moment, wo der Start dann stattfindet, ist es ja erstmal Aufgabe der Launching-Site, ihre Arbeit zu verrichten. Und ich vermute mal, ihr habt dann hier mit schweißnassen Händen hier im schicken Kontrollraum des ESOG hier in Darmstadt gesessen und auf das Signal gewartet, dass der Satellit dann auch wirklich ausgesetzt wurde. Beziehungsweise in dem Moment, was ist denn der erste Moment, wo ihr überhaupt irgendeine Information und Kontrolle bekommt? Das ist dann schon in dem Moment, wo nur noch die Oberstufe mit dem Satelliten alleine im Orbit ist.
Also wir kriegen sämtliche Informationen eigentlich immer in dem Fall von den Russen geliefert. Die haben ja Instrumente an der Rakete selber und an der Oberstufe, die anzeigen, wie sie gerade arbeitet und ob alles okay ist. Die schweißen lassen Hände, fängt ja direkt mit dem Start erstmal an. Also wenn das Ding abhebt, da kann ja tausend Sachen passieren. Ich habe das einmal erlebt in 1996, als die erste Ariane 5 gestartet ist, mit den vier ursprünglichen Cluster-Satelliten. Und die Explosion hat mich lange verfolgt. Also das hat eine Weile gedauert, bis ich das verkraftet hatte. Deshalb, wir sitzen also schon sehr angespannt. Allein in der ersten Phase, wenn das Ding abhebt und man keinerlei Kontrolle hat. Wir können nichts machen. Und erst, wenn dann wirklich der Satellit ausgesetzt ist, wenn wir diese Nachricht bekommen haben, dann beruhigen wir uns erstmal ein bisschen und weisen dann nur noch auf das erste Signal vom Satelliten.
Okay, aber habt ihr dann schon dieses Fregat plus Venus Express Pärchen komplett gesteuert?
Nein, nein.
Das ist immer noch Aufgabe von Baikonur aus.
Wir überdennen den Satelliten in dem Moment, wo er sich von der Oberstufe getrennt hat. Dann macht er bestimmte Bewegungen, die automatisiert sind. Er bootet den Computer und dreht sich mit der Antenne Richtung Erde. Und dann schickt er Signal. Wenn wir dann die ersten Daten auf dem Bildschirm sehen, dann sind erste Jubelstürme da.
Wie lange hat denn das gedauert? Der Launch geht schnell, aber wann wurde die zweite Stufe eingeleitet?
Der macht ein oder zwei Mal um die Erde rum, bevor er dann durchschießt. Wie lange hat das gedauert? Das dauert ungefähr 90 Minuten, bis wir dann wirklich die Abklinkung von der Oberstufe hatten.
Okay, also die Nummer war dann schon so.
Dann dauert es ungefähr nochmal 45 Minuten, bis die internen Satellitensysteme hochgefahren sind und wir dann wirklich auch Daten unten im Kontrollzentrum kriegen.
Dann passt alles noch in einen Werktag.
Ja, das passt da rein. Aber dann die folgenden Wochen, die sind dann anstrengend genug.
Da gibt es eh keinen Urlaub und nichts.
Nein, da arbeiten wir auch noch im Schichtdienst. Da haben wir dann wirklich zwei komplette Teams, die sich abwechseln. Weil in der ersten Phase ist halt noch permanent Kontrolle. 24 Stunden am Tag wird der Satelliten betreut von mehreren Bodenstationen. Und das schafft ein Team natürlich nicht. Irgendwann müssen die auch mal sich ein bisschen ausruhen. Zwei Teams.
Also 12-Stunden-Schicht sozusagen.
Genau, richtig.
Oha.
Und das Ganze dauert dann je nach Komplexität des Satelliten zwei Wochen vielleicht, bis die erste Ausrichtung, die gesamtliche Tests gemacht worden sind, die man fährt alles mal hoch, guckt, ob alles funktioniert. Und dann fängt die sogenannte Cruise-Phase an, wo der Satellit eigentlich nur noch beobachtet wird, Kontrollmanöver hier und da gemacht werden, ab und zu ein kleiner Test. Und diese Cruise-Phase, die dauert dann halt im Prinzip fünf Monate, bis man in dem Fall an der Venus angekommen ist. Aber wir sind nicht tatenlos während dieser fünf Monate. Es sind schon noch diverse Dinge zu tun.
Ja, muss ja auch erstmal alles in Betrieb genommen werden. Und Dinge müssen gegebenenfalls auch schon zu dem Zeitpunkt natürlich getestet werden, ob sie überhaupt noch funktionieren. In einem Fall haben wir ja schon gehört, war es nicht so toll. Kalibriert man dann auch schon irgendwas? Oder ist das eigentlich etwas, was man dann erst vor Ort macht?
Nein, das ist alles in dieser ersten Phase, also in den ersten zwei, drei Wochen nach dem Start werden sämtliche Systeme des Satelliten, der auch eine hohe Redundanz hat, d.h. man hat A- und B-Systeme für alles Mögliche, die werden alle ausprobiert, ob alles funktioniert. Dann werden die Instrumente hochgefahren und es werden kurz mal Daten gesammelt, um zu sehen, ob alles richtig funktioniert, ob der Speichervorgang an Bord des Satelliten funktioniert, ob die Daten runterkommen vom Satelliten, wenn die runtergeladen werden, dass die Bodenstationen das aufnehmen. Das wird alles getestet.
Da ist man wie lange mit beschäftigt?
So 2-3 Wochen ungefähr. Und dann gibt es die gleiche Phase später noch mal, wenn man den Einschuss um den Planeten gemacht hat.
D.h. bei 5 Monaten Flug hat man dann so irgendwann mal vielleicht so 3 Monate dazwischen, wo man eigentlich nur noch wartet?
Weil in Venus Express war das glaube ich auch so der Fall, bei Mars Express war das nicht so der Fall, weil da hatten wir sehr, sehr viele Probleme. Im Prinzip während der gesamten Cruise-Phase bis zu Mars. D.h. da hatten wir keine Freizeit als solche mal zwischendurch. Aber diese ganzen Dinge, die damals passiert sind, sind halt in die Entwicklung von Venus Express auch noch mit eingeflossen, sodass die Cruise-Phase bei Venus Express sehr entspannt war.
Wie kann man das quantifizieren? Wie viele Vorfälle muss man dann unter dem Strich doch noch bearbeiten?
Also richtig heftige Vorfälle bei Mars Express hatten wir so 24-26 Mal. Bei Venus Express insgesamt bis jetzt, inklusive der normalen Routine-Missionen hatten wir 4-5 Mal. Wo was wirklich außergewöhnliches passiert ist. Also da war bei Mars Express doch ganz anderer Zug hinter.
4-5 Mal? Was außergewöhnliches? Dann kann man das ja mal benennen. Was war denn das? Was geht denn da schief?
Bestimmte Systeme sind manchmal nicht richtig eingestellt. Zum Beispiel die sogenannten Star-Tracker, die wir an Bord haben, die die Lage des Satelliten relativ zum westlichen Weltall einstellen. Hat man zum Beispiel bei Mars Express und auch bei Venus Express später noch gesehen, dass die so gebaut sind, dass teilweise Sonnenlicht reinfällt. Und wenn Sonnenlicht in den Star-Tracker reinfällt, dann kann er keine Sterne mehr erkennen.
Weil alles überstrahlt.
Richtig.
So als wenn eine normale Kamera einfach in die Sonne hält.
Genau, bei Mars Express sozusagen direkt nach dem Start. Ups, der kann nix sehen. Das war schon recht heftig. Und man musste sozusagen die Software anpassen. Wir haben dem Satelliten...
Bei Venus Express sind wir jetzt?
Bei Mars Express noch. Weil Venus Express hat die gleichen Star-Tracker, aber auch da wurde gelernt aus dem Problem mit Mars Express. Man hat ihm sozusagen eine Sonnenbrille verpasst. Das alles rausgefiltert, damit da mehr Sterne zu sehen sind für die Kontrolle.
Okay, also das war bei Venus Express unproblematisch.
Ich wollte jetzt mal auf die problematischen Teile kommen. Zwar hat man bei Venus Express ab und zu auch mal Probleme, dass der Computer aus irgendwelchen Gründen aussteigt. Das kann sein, dass zum Beispiel durch Sonnenstürme elektrisch geladene Teilchen auf den Satelliten prallen und die Speicherstipps kurzfristig stören. Und dann steigt der aus und bootet neu, komplett. Das heißt, der dreht sich in seinen Safe Mode, wie man so sagt, seinen sicheren Modus, und geht erstmal Richtung Sonne. Paneele ausrichten Richtung Sonne, damit immer Power da ist. Und dann bootet er seine Systeme neu und dreht sich dann hinterher erst wieder zurück Richtung Erde. Und dann müssen wir gucken, warum hat er das jetzt gemacht, was ist da passiert? Und da kann es dann sein, dass man auch mal auf die B-Instrumente umsteigt, um zu gucken, ob da das Problem auch existiert. Oder ob das ein permanentes Problem ist, dann muss man auf die B-Systeme umsteigen. Oder ob das einfach nur ein Hiccup war sozusagen. Was nicht unbedingt jetzt für die Dauer der Mission ein Problem sein wird. Und kann dann wieder auf den A-System auch bleiben.
Wie muss man sich denn das vorstellen? Das ist ja schon noch jetzt auch die Phase, wo dann diese durchgehenden Schichten gefahren wurden. Man hat zwei komplette Teams, die eigentlich identisch besetzt sein müssen. Auch das Team ist sozusagen A und B, alles redundant. Und man empfängt mehr oder weniger permanent einen Datenstrom vom Satelliten. Und irgendwann geht eine rote Lampe an. Genau, so am besten um 5 Uhr nachts.
In dieser Phase ist man allerdings nicht nur alleine, sondern man hat auch von den Satellitenbauern und von den Entwicklern in SDEC usw. immer Leute vom Projekt da, die sich dann sehr gut in bestimmten Dingen der Hardware auskennen.
Also da im Sinne von im Fernzugriff?
Nein, die sind teilweise auch bei der ESA im Team, im Schichtbetrieb mit drin. Gerade für diese Fälle, wenn da was passiert, dass man gleich die Spezialisten dabei hat.
Also ASTEC, sollte man nochmal kurz erwähnen, die Niederlassung der ESA in Holland. Es gab ja schon einige Berichte von hier. Jetzt konkret dreht es sich hier um das Testcenter. Also da, wo alle Satelliten der ESA durch müssen.
Aber auch die Missionsentwicklung als solche in ASTEC, da ist sozusagen der erste Schritt einer Mission passiert.
Aber, und an der Stelle kann ich auch nochmal verweisen auf die Folge, die wir hier gemacht haben, zum ASTEC-Testcenter selber, wie das dort abläuft, was ein interessanter Aspekt ist und was häufig vergessen wird. Der wird dann nicht nur getestet und funktioniert wunderbar, sondern bei diesen Tests fallen ja alle möglichen Rahmendaten an, die man dann eben in einem solchen Krisenfall schnell heranziehen kann und sagen kann, okay, wir haben dieses Ding ja auch gemessen, wir wissen ganz genau, was jetzt hier die konkreten Grenzbereiche sind und Eigenschaften und wo das Ding vielleicht etwas wackeliger ist und wo wir sagen können, da ist es einfach mal so sicher, da geht nichts schief, dass man dann eben auch solche Sachen heranziehen kann, um sich dann sicher zu sein, dass es das nicht ist oder eben auch eine Vermutung zu entwickeln, dass es das vielleicht sein könnte.
Und dazu kommen dann wirklich noch die, die den Satelliten auch gebaut haben.
Wer war das bei Venus Express?
Das war Astrium. Und dazu kommen dann auch noch die ganzen Wissenschaftler, die die Instrumente entwickelt haben. Auch die sind in der Startphase immer irgendwo mit dabei, besonders dann, wenn wir die Tests mit ihren Instrumenten machen, dass sie direkt auch die Daten ihres eigenen Instrumentes bei uns wirklich in Echtzeit dann empfangen und auch Probleme relativ schnell erkennen können.
Und dieses Computer-Problem, was hatte das dann sozusagen für konkrete Folgen? Also, dann gab es erstmal keine Daten.
Erstmal keine. Und dann gibt es mehrere Folgen. Je nachdem, wo dann das Problem eigentlich sitzt, wird entweder die Software angepasst, wenn es ein Softwareproblem war, oder wenn es ein Problem war, mit dem eigentlichen Bedienung des Computers, dass man irgendwie Schritte zu schnell abgearbeitet hat oder in der falschen Reihenfolge, dann werden die Prozeduren angepasst. Oder wenn tatsächlich es so ist, dass das ein Hardware-Problem ist, dann geht man auf die redundante Einheit.
Aber wie ist das jetzt konkret gelaufen in dem Fall? War das jetzt das erste Ereignis? Du hast ja gesagt, es gab nur vier oder fünf Fälle, wo wirklich was schiefgegangen ist.
Das sind meistens Computer oder von einem Speicherekorder gewesen, der Fehler produziert hat. Wir haben bisher nicht auf redundante Systeme umswitchen müssen. Es war immer klar, dass es nur ein temporärer Fehler war. Dann hat man schnell die Software angepasst, um dieses Problem zu vermeiden.
Die einzige Ausnahme ist das kaputte Instrument.
Das kaputte Instrument kann man gar nichts machen. Aber alles, was man machen kann, durch Umschalten, durch andere Prozeduren, durch andere Reihenfolgen, wie man Dinge bedient, kriegt man sehr viel in den Griff.
Mich würde interessieren, wie ihr da organisatorisch umgeht. Es gibt eine Warnmeldung oder einen Datenstromausfall. Wenn der Computer nicht reagiert, kommt wahrscheinlich nichts mehr.
Alle aus ihren Betten rutschen an der Stange herunter? Meistens ist es so mit den Satelliten wie Venus Express, die eine feste Hauptantenne haben. Solange die Daten gesendet werden, ist sozusagen alles gut. Wenn plötzlich mal die Bodenstation sich ausrichtet, zum Satelliten keine Daten kommen, denkt man schon, ups. Da geht es dann schon mal los. Da ruft man dann schon mal die ersten Leute an. Dann wird getestet. Wie ist es an der Bodenstation?
Wird dann auch das B-Team aktiviert, oder das A-Team, je nachdem, welches gerade gerade ist?
Man ruft das A-Team sozusagen. Beide Teams gleichzeitig eigentlich nicht. Es kommt immer drauf an, wenn das jetzt sehr zum Ende der Schicht des ersten war, dann kann man die Jungs auch schon mal eine halbe Stunde früher reinholen, um das dann zu bearbeiten. In dem Fall, man muss erstmal testen, ob die Bodenstation richtig funktioniert. Die hat ja auch sehr viele technische Komponenten. Hat die sich richtig ausgerichtet? Ist der Output groß genug? Das wird erstmal getestet. Wenn da alles in Ordnung ist, dann wartet man auf irgendwelche Signale vom Satelliten. Wir wissen, dass zum Beispiel Venus Express und Mars Express ungefähr 45 Minuten brauchen, um sich wieder Richtung Erde auszurichten. Das heißt, man wartet dann ab erstmal. Und wenn dann ein Signal kommt, dann weiß man, aha, der ist im Safe-Mode gewesen. Dann wird jetzt langsam das System komplett wieder hochgefahren. Da wird überall geguckt, woran es hätte liegen können. Er hat ja auch Fehler speicher. Das heißt, er sagt einem eigentlich schon, was nicht funktioniert hat. Er sagt nicht warum, aber er sagt zumindest, was, wo, genau, in welcher Ecke nicht funktioniert hat. Und diese Daten nimmt man erstmal auf.
Und es ist auch so, dass er nach diesen 45 Minuten immer wieder kam. Also das war jetzt nicht so, dass das mal ein paar Stunden Schicht war, sondern gar so eine Pause.
Bisher haben wir das noch nicht erlebt, dass er wirklich ganz weg war. Das wäre schwierig, weil dann müsste man irgendwann anfangen, sozusagen auf gut Glück einfach mit der Bodenstation ein paar Signale zu schicken, um zu gucken, ob er die aufhängt oder nicht. Aber das haben wir zum Glück nie erlebt. Er ist immer brav wieder zur Erde zurückgekommen. Wenn man jetzt diese ganzen Daten runtergeladen hat, das dauert halt eine Weile, je nach Entfernung, je nach Datenmenge, dann wird das erstmal gesichtet. Nebenbei ist ein anderer Teil des Teams damit beschäftigt, festzustellen, ob der Satellit so im Moment sicher ist oder ob irgendwelche speziellen Dinge noch gemacht werden müssen, damit nicht gleich noch irgendwas passiert.
Weil es ja sein kann, dass der Fehler eben auch ein echtes Vielverhalten nach sich gezogen hat, was korrigiert werden müsste.
Und die anderen, die nehmen sich jetzt die Daten vor. Und dann zieht man sich zurück, meistens aus dem Kontrollraum, in extra Briefing-Raum, und dann diskutiert man erst mal aus, wer was gesehen hat, wer welche Idee hat, warum das so ist. Dann wird getestet, wenn wir das und das machen können, haben wir schon eine Prozedur dafür. Ist das vorher schon mal ausgedacht gewesen, dass so was passieren kann, dann haben wir auch so genannte Rettungsprozeduren, die solche Sachen abarbeiten können. Je nachdem, was man alles bedacht hat.
Man hat sich schon vorher Gedanken gemacht, wenn das passiert, dann müsste man so und so.
Das ist Teil der Missionsvorbereitung, sich mit möglichen Fehlern zu beschäftigen. Damit man nicht zu viel Zeit braucht. In dem Fall war es so, dass man die Prozeduren hatte und Testprogramme laufen lassen kann in bestimmten Einheiten. Dann wird ein Zeitplan aufgestellt, wann man was macht.
Wo laufen die Programme dann? Auf dem Satelliten?
Ja, die laufen auf dem Satelliten. Die kann man aktivieren, so Testprogramme.
Die genau für diese Fälle zugeschnitten sind. Teil der Software sind von vornherein. Prozedur heißt nicht nur, man hat einen Zettel, wo drauf steht, wen man anrufen soll. Prozedur heißt, der Satellit selber ist vorbereitet, diese Fehler zu analysieren. Man muss es nur noch aktivieren.
Man muss einige Sachen mitberechnen. Wie lange haben wir noch Kontakt mit der Bodenstation? Es wird ein Zeitplan aufgestellt, wann wir überhaupt was machen können. Es kann sein, dass man irgendwelche Eklipsen hat, wo man gerade hinter dem Planeten verschwunden ist. Oder man weiß, dass bestimmte, zum Beispiel die Monde bei den Star Trekern sind, die gerade mal nicht die relevanten Daten haben. Das weiß man alles vorher. Dann kann man einen Plan ausstellen, zu dem und dem Zeitpunkt versuchen wir das und das. Und dann geht man halt ran. Und Step by Step geht man vorwärts, guckt sich die Ecke an, wo wirklich was gewesen ist, lässt diese Testprogramme laufen. Und eventuell muss man dann halt bestimmte Dinge anpassen. Oder auch nicht, wenn man feststellt, das war jetzt wohl nur ein sogenannter Single Event Upset. Das passiert ab und zu mal. Allein, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, wenn irgendwelche Sonnenstürme oder so etwas, elektrisch geladene Teilchen auf die Satelliten abschießen, da gibt es dann eine Kurzzeit-Verwirrung teilweise im System, die dann aber wieder verschwindet.
dem System ist einfach nur mal kurz schwindlig geworden und hat jetzt wieder Luft und geht wieder. Das ist einfach normal, das hat man schon geahnt. Das passiert dann halt so.
Das haben wir bei Venus Express gerade jetzt in letzter Zeit, als die ersten Sonnenstürme in diesem 11-Jahres-Zyklus der Sonne wieder aufgetreten sind, da war wirklich eine Sonneneruption, die wirklich gerade genau Richtung Venus ging. Die hat die Erde nicht besonders stark abgekriegt, aber die Venus ist halt voll getroffen worden. Und Venus Express hat diese zwei Star-Trekker ja an Bord, und die waren blind für, ich glaube, 48 Stunden komplett. Das heißt, wir konnten keine direkte Lagekontrolle machen, die basiert ja auf den Star-Trekker. Wir haben jetzt noch Kreisel-Systeme, die sozusagen im Moment den Satelliten auch halten. Aber wie alle diese Kreisel-Systeme, die haben eine bestimmte Drift, die eigentlich ausgeglichen werden soll durch die Star-Trekker-Messungen.
Wo sie sich dann immer wieder neu kalibrieren und so.
Wenn die nicht kommen, dann driftet der halt ganz langsam weg vom Erdpoint.
So wie eine Digital-Uhr nach 14 Tagen einfach auch mal in zwei Sekunden falsch läuft.
Richtig, genau, so kann man sich das vorstellen. Und da muss man dann halt gegensteuern. Das heißt, da gibt es bei den Flugdynamikern Berechnen dann sozusagen in etwa, wo man den Satellit mal kalibrieren kann, in welchem Winkel der gerade noch Richtung Erde läuft, dass wir auch die Signale wieder haben und auch Kommandos hochschieben können. Das hat wie gesagt 48 Stunden gedauert, bis dieses Blenden der Star-Tracker wirklich auch wieder weg war.
Hat man denn diese Sonnenwind-Geschichte erst dadurch bemerkt, dass eben ein Ausfall war? Oder ist man da schon in der interstellaren Wettervorhersage so gut gewusstet?
In dem Fall war der Sonnensturm nicht auf der eher zugewandten Seite ausgebrochen. Die meisten Satelliten, die wir zur Sonnenbeobachtung haben, sind halt zwischen uns und der Sonne. Aber in dem Fall war es nicht sichtbar. Das heißt, wir sind richtig hart getroffen worden. Erst dann wussten wir, aha, da war ein Sonnensturm.
Gut, genau, jetzt muss man ja nochmal zurückholen. Also 2005 war der Start, 2006 im Januar, Februar? April, genau. Da war man dann da und seitdem kreist Venus Express um die Venus. Richtig. Aber die Venus kreist ja auch munter weiter um die Sonne. Das heißt, jetzt kann die irgendwo sein. Wir sind auf der einen Seite der Sonne, auf der anderen Seite sind die beiden. Man hat auch vielleicht gar keinen unmittelbaren Funkkontakt. Und wenn da jetzt mal eine Eruption ist, dann weiß man es nicht mit. Die einzige Möglichkeit wäre, dass man jetzt mit den Satelliten, die die Sonnen vor Ort beobachten, da gibt es ja auch...
Richtig, da gibt es einige. Und einige sind auch ein bisschen so am Rand stationiert. Aber die können nicht komplett die ganze Sonne abdecken und sozusagen eine Warnung geben, dass da wieder eine Eruption kommt.
Also in dem Fall traf es einen unvorbereitet. Aber zumindest wusste man auch, es gab zumindest eine Kommunikation zwischen Express und Erde.
Als wir das gesehen haben, dass die Star Trekker nicht mehr arbeiten, ist sofort die erste Vermutung. Gucken wir uns mal an, was der für einen Background-Noise drauf hat.
Was hat man denn da für eine maximale Verzögerung? Ich meine, wenn die Venus jetzt auf der anderen Seite der Sonne ist, dann ist das ja schon ein nicht ganz unerheblicher Abstand zu Erde.
Das kann bis 20 Minuten ungefähr dauern. Und das ist halt das Problem mit interplanetaren Operationen. Im Prinzip sind Dinge am Satelliten schon passiert, die wir nach 20 Minuten erst sehen. Das heißt, auch Kommandos...
Und die haben doch schon sofort Maßnahmen ergreifen, die aber dann ja auch frühestens in 20 Minuten überhaupt greifen können. Und dann muss man vielleicht noch mal 20 Minuten nachdenken. Also man hängt einfach eine Stunde hinterher. Aber in dem Moment ist dann auch schon echt Alarm.
Weil das ist kein Zustand, in dem der Satellit relativ lange bleiben kann. Weil irgendwann driftet er mit der Antenne von der Erde weg und dann wird es ganz schwierig, Kommandos hochzuschicken noch. Weil dann hat er zwar noch so zwei Reserveantennen, die im Vergleich zu der eingerichteten Antenne sozusagen omnidirektional arbeiten, aber die sind wesentlich schwächer. Und auf die Entfernung ist es schon wirklich ganz, ganz schwierig, Telemetrie überhaupt zu bekommen. Aber es reicht wahrscheinlich gerade noch, wenn man mit den ganz großen Antennen, den 70-Meter-Antennen, mit ordentlich Power ein Kommando in diese kleinen Antennen reinsteckt. Ist aber keine Garantie, dass das wirklich funktioniert.
Jetzt muss es ja eigentlich so, weiß nicht, wie ich das jetzt rechnen soll, aber so gefühlt vielleicht auch mehr als einmal im Jahr diesen Fall geben, die Venus ist halt auf der anderen Seite der Sonne. Dann ist sie ja wirklich komplett verdeckt. Und das wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur für ein paar Minuten, sondern über einen längeren Zeitraum. Ein paar Tage dauert das. Das heißt, man weiß vorher schon, es gibt da so eine Woche, da ist dann einfach gar nichts. Wenn in dem Moment jetzt so eine Sonnenwindkatastrophe passiert, wie ist man denn darauf vorbereitet? Also muss ja das System sich selbst schützen.
Das ist einer dieser Fälle, wo man nicht im Prinzip eingreifen kann. Man kann nicht alles abdecken. Wir machen das meistens so, dass wir keinerlei wichtigen Operationen in dieser Zeit planen. Das heißt im Prinzip, selbst wenn er hinter der Sonne verschwindet, bleibt er in einer bestimmten Lage. Man macht also nicht noch große Wissenschaftsuntersuchungen. Man vermeidet alles, woraus dann irgendwie ein Fehler entstehen könnte in dem Fall. Aber der Satellit selbst hat auch gewisse Timer, die man einstellen kann, für wie lange er wirklich ohne Erdkontrolle sein kann, bevor er von sich aus in den Safe Mode geht. Das kann man anpassen, je nachdem, wie lange man wirklich keinen Kontakt wegen des Verschwindens hinter der Sonne hat.
Wie ist das dann ausgegangen mit dem Sonnenwind?
Nach 48 Stunden merken wir, dass langsam das Hintergrundrauschen verschwand.
Wie war denn zu dem Zeitpunkt die Kommunikationsposition?
Die Kreiselsysteme sind sehr gut und die haben den wirklich festgehalten. Wir brauchten da nicht groß was machen.
Wie viel Verzögerung gab es im Signalweg zu dem Zeitpunkt? Wie lange hat das überhaupt gedauert?
Ich denke, das Signalweg war so um die 15 Minuten zu dem Zeitpunkt. Er war die ganze Zeit auf die Erde ausgerichtet. Das heißt, wir haben die Daten permanent gekriegt. Flight Dynamics hat kurz kalibriert. Wir haben eine kleine Bewegung vom Satelliten eingegeben, um die Erde herum, damit man genau sieht, wo die Grenzen sind und wann man wirklich was gegensteuern müsste, um die Position zur Erde länger halten zu können.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Der Satellit selber?
Ja, man nutzt so das Signal der Antenne. Der Satellit macht so eine Kreiselbewegung mit der Antenne und kalibriert daraus sozusagen den...
Ah, verstehe. Er tastet sozusagen alle möglichen Positionen ab und schaut, wo jetzt wirklich am besten empfangen werden kann.
Daraus kann man dann wieder die Kreiseldrift kompensieren. Im Prinzip aus diesem Scan-Modus.
Ah, weil man sich dann sozusagen... Man hat zwar nicht die Sterne, aber man hat immer noch die Erde und von der weiß man ja auch, wo sie ist. Pfffisch. Ah, das ist ja pfffisch.
Und da kann man das dann eingeben und dann kann man es notfalls noch länger halten. Aber wie gesagt, nach 48 Stunden war das Ganze vorbei und kaum dass der erste Stern wieder sichtbar war, war alles wieder in Ordnung.
Das ist ja ein schönes Beispiel, um sich auch klar zu machen, dass jetzt so mit der Berechnung des Flugwegs und mit Gravitation etc. noch lange nicht alles trockenen Tüchern ist. Nein, nein, nein.
Es gibt Unwägbarkeiten und Unwägbarkeiten.
Sonnenwind ist natürlich jetzt eine sehr offensichtliche Störtätigkeit. Also selbst wenn man sie nicht sofort mitbekommt, man weiß, dass sie eben droht. Was gibt es denn sonst noch so für potenzielle Bedrohungen, jenseits der Sonnenaktivität, die noch so unvorhergesehen sind? Das ist eigentlich der einzige wirklich dynamische Faktor an der Stelle.
Der einzige dynamische Faktor eigentlich. Es kann, je näher man an der Sonne dran ist, auch mal ein thermisches Problem geben. Dass irgendwelche Seiten des Satelliten, man hat ja vorher ausgerechnet, wo sind welche Instrumente innen drin und welche Seiten des Satelliten dürfen wir überhaupt mit der Sonne beleuchten, ohne dass es wirklich große Temperaturausschläge gibt, die wirklich dann einen schlechten Effekt haben können auf diverse Teile. Wenn da was kaputt geht, und wir haben das bei Venus Express erlebt, damals als er zum ersten Mal hinter der Sonne verschwunden ist, war die Hauptantenne direkt sozusagen in die Sonne ausgerichtet. Und das hat höchstwahrscheinlich entweder Lötstellen oder Kabelkontakte vorne an der Antenne nicht ganz gelöst, aber zumindest so stark beeinflusst, dass einer der Transponder, der die Signale generiert in einem bestimmten Band, nicht mehr nutzbar ist. Da hat sich wirklich irgendwas gelöst. Woraufhin wir bei den nächsten Mal, wo die Sonne direkt auf die Antenne geschehen hätte, uns entschlossen haben, den Satellit leicht wegzudrehen. Da man hinter der Sonne ja sowieso keinen Kontakt hat, kann man den in eine Richtung drehen, wo dieser thermische Effekt am geringsten ist.
Aber heißt das dann, die Instrumente aufhören zu arbeiten, weil sie dann nicht mehr in die richtige Richtung gucken?
Genau deshalb machen wir auch keine wissenschaftlichen Beobachtungen. Das nennt sich eine sogenannte Cooling Attitude. Das heißt, da wird der Satellit wirklich so gestellt, dass möglichst wenig Wärme aufgenommen wird. Und da sind alle Instrumente aus, in dem Fall. Und das kann man nicht riskieren, in dem Fall da noch großartige Operationen zu machen.
Also man ist jetzt auch nicht komplett ausgeliefert, wie im Normalbetrieb, sondern man weiß, jetzt gibt es eh keine Kommunikation, wir können jetzt nicht viel retten, dann bringen wir uns mal gleich in die bestmögliche Wartestellung und dann gibt es dann einfach mal eine Woche keine Daten.
Zumal ja auch jede wissenschaftliche Untersuchung produziert eine bestimmte Menge Daten und wir haben einen Festplattenspeicher an Bord, der nur eine definierte Größe hat. Wenn man jetzt ein paar Tage keinen Kontakt hätte und trotzdem pausenlos Beobachtungen machen würde, dann wäre irgendwann der Speicher voll und man wird die eigenen Daten wieder überschreiben. Und das ist natürlich auch kontraproduktiv, das wollen die Wissenschaftler natürlich auch nicht, deshalb akzeptieren die halt, dass es für ein paar Tage halt keine Untersuchungen gibt, um halt das zu vermeiden.
Dann können die sicher auch mal ihren Urlaub entsprechend liegen.
Genau.
Wann machst du Urlaub? Na ja, wenn die Venus hinter der Sonne verschwindet.
Du lachst jetzt, aber das ist wirklich so. Selbst wir hier bei der ESOG sagen, an den Tagen haben wir keinen Kontakt. Wenn jemand möchte, bitte nehmt euch ein paar Tage Urlaub, weil es ist sowieso nichts, was wir tun können. Man muss flexibel sein.
Man plant ja seinen Urlaub gerne nach der Sonnenaktivität. In dem Fall in einer ganz anderen Dimension.
Nach der Sonnenaktivität planen wird schwierig. Dafür ist sie viel zu unberechenbar.
Man weiß ja, im Sommer ist es wärmer, dann fährt man dann halt mal an den Strand. Das würde man im Winter so nicht machen. Hier richtet man sich dann nach der Venus. Das ist interessant. Das ist auch so wie mit denen, die an Mars-Missionen arbeiten, dass sie nicht selten auch in den Mars-Tag eingetaktet werden, der etwas länger ist als der Erdentag. Da holt man dann immer wieder 40 Minuten pro Tag mehr auf. Das ist der alte Traum von Virgil Holligs, die gerne mal einen längeren Tag hätten.
Da muss man in den Raumfahrt gehen, da hat man sowas.
Aber mit dem Venus-Tag habt ihr so nichts direkt zu tun?
Nein, wir haben dadurch, dass wir ein relativ kleines Team haben, wirklich den großen Vorteil, dass die Venus näher an der Sonne dran ist als wir. Das heißt, wenn wir mit unserer Bodenstation in Madrid Kontakt haben, dann ist es immer zur Tageszeit. Es verschiebt sich leicht, je nachdem, wo die Venus gerade steht im Jahr. Aber es ist immer während der normalen Tagesarbeitszeit, wo wir Kontakt haben. Man könnte natürlich auch noch eine Bodenstation nehmen auf der anderen Seite der Erde. Dann hätte man wahrscheinlich auch noch die Möglichkeit, da dann auch noch Daten zu bekommen. Aber wie gesagt, wenn man so viele Daten sammelt, dann ist irgendwann der Speicher auch oben voll. Und es macht keinen Sinn, wirklich so viele Observationen zu machen, dass wir wirklich alle paar Stunden eine Bodenstation brauchen, um das ganze Zeug auch wieder runterzugeben. Also es ist dadurch wesentlich entspannter.
Was für Festplatten? Sind da wirklich Festplatten an Bord?
Ja, nennt sich so.
Aber sind jetzt keine drehenden Scheiben?
Nein? Bei den älteren Satelliten, da waren es wirklich noch Rekorder. Das waren wirklich noch Bandgeräte. Aber das sind alles nur Festplatten. Speicher im Prinzip.
Also man verwendet da jetzt einfach Chips als Speicher?
Genau, Chips.
Und was ist die Kapazität?
Wir haben, glaube ich, bei Venus Express 10 Gigabit, die wir speichern können. Bei Mars Express war es noch etwas weniger. Ja, 1 Bit sind 8 Bit. Da kann man ungefähr ausrechnen, wie viel wir weiter.
Ja, ein bisschen mehr als eine Fehlerkorrektur.
Genau, da ist natürlich aufgeteilt. Für die Plattform ist ein Bereich vorgesehen. Und für jedes Instrument ist ein Bereich vorgesehen. Also für die gesamten wissenschaftlichen Daten.
Ist das viel? Also im Verhältnis für Missionen? Das muss ja dann auch alles erst mal übertragen werden. Wie schnell kann man das denn von dem Satelliten wieder runterholen?
Das ist unterschiedlich. Je nachdem, wie nah wir an der Venus dran sind, können wir die Datenrate hochfahren oder auch nicht. Also wir haben so 228 Kilobit pro Sekunde, wenn wir nah dran sind mit der großen Antenne. Wenn wir sehr weit weg sind, geht das runter bis auf 38 Kilobit pro Sekunde.
Okay, das ist schon eine Schwankung. Das heißt, man kann eigentlich gar nicht alles übertragen, was gemessen wird?
Doch, weil das wird ja geplant. Die wissenschaftlichen Observationen werden so geplant, dass die Datenmenge nur so groß ist, dass wir sie am nächsten Tag auch wieder runterladen können. Ab und zu haben wir ein bisschen mehr, aber dadurch haben wir sozusagen einen Langzeitplanungsstab. Und dann werden Kurzfristplanungen noch gemacht. Das heißt, man weiß schon für die Langfristplanung, wie viel man insgesamt produziert hat, für sagen wir mal vier Wochen. Da kann es dann durchaus sein, dass an ein, drei, fünf, sechs Tagen mal mehr produziert wird, als wir runterladen. Aber es wird nie die Kapazität des Rekorders überschritten. Das heißt, es gibt, weil auch viele Instrumente nicht unbedingt immer an sind, die haben immer nur so Zeiten, wo sie zwischendurch mal an sind, je nachdem, wo sie gerade hingucken. Die müssen sich auch einigen untereinander, in welche Richtung die eigentliche Observationsplattform von Venus Express zeigt. Da gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche Vorlieben. Einige wollen sozusagen am Rand vorbei gucken von der Venus, um die Atmosphäre dadurch zu sehen. Andere wollen direkt runter gucken auf die Venus, um die Wolkenformation zu sehen. Oder leicht abgewandelt irgendwohin, weil sie da in irgendwelchen Wellenlängen was anderes machen. Da müssen die sich alle untereinander einigen.
Das heißt, die sind alle starr verbunden. Die können nicht unterschiedlich voneinander mit dem eigenen Motor irgendwo hingucken. Sondern man muss schon sagen, heute benutzen wir mal das Instrument. Dazu müssen wir uns dahin ausrichten, dann müssen die anderen halt sehen, wie sie damit klarkommen.
Es gibt Instrumente an Bord, denen ist es wurscht. Das sind welche, die ein großes Spektrum abarbeiten. Die können sowohl Observationen machen, wenn sie nah an der Venus dran sind, als auch wenn sie am Venus entferntesten Punkt sind. Zum Beispiel dieses eine Magnetometer, dem ist es egal. Der ist immer an und läuft. Davon haben wir ein, zwei Instrumente, aber die anderen sind wirklich direktional. Wir müssen wirklich dahin gucken, auf eine bestimmte Stelle. Das wird in diesem Wissenschaftsplan aufgearbeitet. Das heißt, da wird eine Planung gemacht, relativ grob, so für ein halbes Jahr, dann wird es schon feiner für einen Monat. Und dann machen wir jede Woche noch mal eine Kurzplanung, falls irgendwelche Änderungen, andere Wünsche sind usw. Das wird jedes Mal einmal die Woche die Kommandos für die ganze Woche generiert, die dann in Blöcken jeden Tag hochgeladen werden.
Und dann ist es sozusagen auf die Minute genau, jetzt das, jetzt das, jetzt das.
Der Satellit hat dann oben einen großen Speicher, wo er die Kommandos alle sammelt und genau zu der Zeit ausführt, die wir vorgegeben haben. Da passen maximal 3.000 Kommandos rein in diesen Puffer. Hochladen tun wir pro Tag um die 1.000. Also wäre noch Platz.
Also man sendet auch nicht wirklich so ein Tu-jetzt-genau-das-Kommando hoch, sondern man gibt ihm quasi den Plan für die nächste Fahrt?
Ab und zu ja, für Wissenschaft nicht. Aber wenn wir bestimmte Tests mit dem Satellit machen, da schicken wir manchmal auch schon Kommandos, die direkt ausgeführt werden. Direkt ist natürlich relativ wieder im Sonnensystem.
So direkt, wie es geht halt.
Genau, so direkt, wie es geht. Wenn wir Glück haben, sind es nur 3 Minuten, wenn wir Pech haben, sind es 20. Da werden auch Kommandos geschickt, die direkt ausgearbeitet. Aber das hat mit Wissenschaftskommandos eigentlich nichts zu tun. Das geht dann eher um den Satelliten und die Steuerung.
Wie groß ist das Team, was sich jetzt konkret um die Flugsteuerung kümmert?
Sieben. Wir sind sieben Ingenieure.
Und wie viele Leute kümmern sich um diesen wissenschaftlichen Teil? Weil an der Stelle ist es ja sozusagen ein bisschen entkoppelt von dem eigentlichen Flugbetrieb. Und sind das dann noch die Leute, die die Entscheidung fällen, wer jetzt darf oder wird das woanders ausgewürfelt?
Nein, also wie genau so die Wissenschaftsteams aussehen, weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau. Wir haben bestimmte Ansprechpartner bei jedem Instrument, bei jedem Wissenschaftler, der irgendwas da untersucht.
Aber die müssen ja dann auch untereinander. Ich meine, die können ja in Konflikt stehen. Die einen wollen dahin gucken, die anderen wollen dahin gucken und beide zum gleichen Zeitpunkt.
Und die setzen sich alle zusammen in dieser Vorplanung des Ganzen, dass man grob absteckt, was man so machen will. Und das wird dann sozusagen zu unseren eigentlichen Planner. Die sitzen in Madrid. Die planen die Science-Observation im Kontext Satellitbewegungen und so weiter und so fort. Die müssen alles Mögliche bedenken. Nicht nur, dass die Instrumente an- und ausgeschaltet werden. Die müssen entwerfen, wohin unsere Flugdynamiker sozusagen den Satelliten richten sollen. Was unsere Flugdynamiker dann wieder in Kommandos umsetzen, die wir dann wieder bekommen und die wir dann hochladen. Also es ist alles eine große Familie, sag ich mal, die zusammenarbeiten muss, damit wirklich das Endprodukt, nämlich die Kommandos, für den nächsten Tag oder die nächste Woche, am Ende dabei rauskommen.
Das heißt, die Wissenschaftsteams müssen sich eigentlich untereinander darüber im Klaren werden, in welcher generellen Reihenfolge sie vorgehen. Das betrifft euch jetzt sozusagen nicht unmittelbar. Und ihr kriegt eben die Grobplanung und müsst dann eben sagen, okay, alles klar, das ist das, was ihr wollt. Hier haben wir noch so eine Realität, die habt ihr noch nicht bedacht.
Genau so läuft das. Teilweise geht das zwei-, dreimal hin und her, bis dann wirklich alle sicher sind, dass das auch sicher für den Satelliten ist. Weil es gibt bestimmte Bedingungen, die eingehalten werden müssen. Zum Beispiel, dass man nicht jede Seite des Satelliten überhaupt beleuchten darf von der Sonne her. Das heißt, es müssen Bewegungen gemacht werden, die genau diese Seiten aussparen. Und das sind alles so kleinere Richtlinien. Davon gibt es eine ganze Menge. Wo sich diese Wissenschaftler daran halten müssen.
Jetzt haben wir den Start und den Flug, die Testerei, das haben wir jetzt alles schon ganz gut besprochen. Was wir vorhin ein bisschen rausgelassen haben, ist so die eigentliche Eintrittsphase, die ja auf Anhieb funktioniert hat, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Man ist halt angekommen, dieses Bremsmanöver wurde gestartet, seitdem befindet man sich im Orbit. In was für einem Orbit befindet sich dieser Satellit denn eigentlich? Tatsächlich ist das eine flexible Geschichte oder ist der da immer am selben Ort?
Der ist in dem Fall immer am selben Ort. Wir haben eine polare Umlaufbahn, das heißt, er geht über die Pole der Venus hinweg.
Wie ein Erdbeobachtungssatellit, das meistens auch macht.
Genau, und sie ist hocheliptisch. Das heißt, der nächste Punkt oben am Nordpol liegt je nach Saison zwischen 200, 400 Kilometern. Und der entfernteste Punkt liegt, glaube ich, bei 70.000 Kilometern. Das heißt, es ist eine große Ellipse, die Venus Express da beschreibt. Und die ist so ausgeklügelt, dass sie genau 24 Stunden dauert. Das heißt, man hat genau einen Umlauf um die Venus pro Tag.
Pro Erdtag.
Pro Erdtag, genau. Und je nachdem, wo der... Das ist die Missionsplanung, die Einfachheit der Planung, dass man wirklich am Tag 10 Stunden sozusagen Kontakt hat. Wo man eigentlich auch für alle Instrumente an einem Tag immer alles unterkriegen könnte. In der ursprünglichen Missionsentwicklung haben sich die natürlich auch alle zusammengesetzt und sich ausgesucht, was für ein Orbit ist denn am effektivsten für uns alle. Und dabei ist herausgekommen, dass für die am effektivsten ist, wenn wirklich der Venus nächste Punkt am Nordpol sozusagen ist und dann der entfernteste Punkt am Südpol. Weil am Südpol konnte man dann die gesamte Venus im Prinzip sehen mit diesen beiden Wirbeln. Die einfach besonders spannend waren. Im Prinzip ist dieses Orbit also fest. Es gibt allerdings dadurch, dass die Gravitation der Sonne ja auch eine Rolle spielt, leichte Verschiebung in diesem Orbit. Und je nachdem hat das halt den Effekt, dass Venus Express am nächsten Punkt automatisch runtergezogen wird. Oder zu einer anderen Zeit, wenn der Venus nächste Punkt auf der anderen Seite ist, hochgedrückt wird von der Gravitation. Und da muss man halt dann immer wieder mit den Triebwerken anpassen. Weil wenn wir zu seit runtergezogen werden, dann macht es irgendwann Puff und Wegware. Oder wenn er zu weit rausgeschoben wird, dann stimmt der ganze Scienceplan nicht mehr. Und das muss man dann immer anpassen.
Die Venus hat ja jetzt eine extrem dichte und dramatische Atmosphäre. Das ist ja für Erdmissionen, ich meine 200 Kilometer, ist ja verdammt nah eigentlich.
Da sind wir auch schon fast in der Atmosphäre drin.
Das heißt, der Bremseffekt der Atmosphäre dürfte ja auch nicht zu vernachlässigen sein.
Richtig, deshalb darf man nicht zu tief kommen. Normalerweise, also in den ersten Jahren, gab es auch noch nicht so den Drang, wirklich mal weiter runterzukommen und die Atmosphäre aus nächster Nähe zu sehen. Da war im Schnitt die Höhe 350 bis 400 Kilometer. Da ist man definitiv sehr weit draußen.
Aber der Respekt noch sehr groß.
Erst jetzt in den letzten Jahren hat man sich auch überlegt, können wir nicht da noch ein bisschen mehr, sozusagen, erfahren über die Atmosphäre, wenn wir ein bisschen näher rankommen. Plus dann irgendwann auch die Idee noch kam, dadurch, dass ja für viele der Landemissionen auch auf anderen Planeten häufig das sogenannte Aerobraking benutzt wird, um den Satelliten abzubremsen und in einen bestimmten Orbit zu bekommen. Die ESA das aber noch nie gemacht hat. Und auch für weitere Missionen auch mal einen Rover abzusetzen. Einfach aus Erfahrung es gut wäre, mal zu probieren, wie sowas eigentlich funktioniert. Und daraus entwickelte sich dann so langsam halt die Idee, dass man den Satelliten ein bisschen weiter runterkommen lässt und ihn wirklich in die Atmosphäre leicht eintauchen lässt. Und von der Bewegung des Satelliten kann man dann die Dichte der Atmosphäre relativ schnell berechnen. Und auch berechnen, wie weit man wirklich runterkommen kann, bevor es dann irgendwann ganz gefährlich wird.
Von der Vibration her, der Bewegung oder eine Ablenkung?
Erstmal wird ja gebremst. Und dadurch, dass die Sonnenpaneele von Venus Express meistens vertikal stehen, kriegt man einen Kippmoment natürlich durch den Fall.
Das heißt, das eine Segel taucht früher ein als das andere und wird dann so umgedreht?
Und es gibt natürlich thermische Probleme in dem Fall natürlich. Dadurch, dass die Atmosphäre sehr dicht ist, hat man halt auch relativ schnell einen thermischen Effekt. Und das muss man natürlich kontrollieren, weil irgendwann wird es dann zu heiß und dann fällt das Ding irgendwann mal auseinander. Also das muss man jetzt auch möglichst vermeiden natürlich.
Heißt denn dichte Atmosphäre auch, dass sie dicker ist als die der Erde? Oder bewegt es sich im selben Höhenbereich auch?
Sie ist sehr kompakt und hat eine sehr definierte Eingangshöhe. Das heißt, man kommt sozusagen von nichts auf 100 relativ schnell. Bei anderen Planeten, Erde und Mars zum Beispiel auch, da fängt das leicht an und wird ganz langsam stärker.
Das heißt, die Atmosphäre muss man sich mehr wie so einen großen Gas-Ozean vorstellen?
Genau, das könnte man sich so vorstellen, in den Venus Express ganz leicht eintaucht.
Und wenn man nur so ein bisschen zu tief ist, dann kann es auch schon zu spät sein. Das heißt, man pirscht sich da jetzt langsam ran.
Ich hatte ja vorhin schon erwähnt, dass teilweise das Orbit von der Sonne, von der Gravitation bestimmt wird und dieser Venusnächste Punkt teilweise näher, teilweise weiter weg ist. Es gibt einen Zwischenpunkt zwischen diesen beiden Effekten, wo es relativ konstant ist, wo kein direkter Einfluss ist. Und im Moment suchen wir uns diese Plateaus im Prinzip, um da diese Untersuchungen zu machen. Weil da ist die Chance halt größer, dass der Satellit keinen Schaden nehmen kann, weil wir nicht relativ schnell absacken können durch das Abbremsen.
Und wie weit ist das dann von der Oberfläche entfernt?
Im Moment machen wir gerade wieder so einen Test, da sind wir bei 165 Kilometern.
Das heißt, im Vergleich zur Erde ist die Atmosphäre auch viel höher. Also ich meine, bei 100 Kilometern ist ja bei der Erde im Wesentlichen...
Ja, so ein bisschen weiter raus geht es schon noch. Also da ist noch was, aber man sagt ja, da fängt das Weltall an, da ist die Atmosphäre nicht mehr so dominant. Genau, und wir wissen inzwischen, dass die Atmosphäre ungefähr bei 180 Kilometer bei der Venus, 180-190 Kilometer anfängt. Das variiert auch je nach Sonnentätigkeit. Teilweise wird die etwas aufgeblasen, teilweise wird sie etwas unterdruckt.
Also man fliegt extrem dicht über so einen brodelnden Planeten, das heißt Gasplaneten gesagt, also man macht so den Eindruck, aber es ist halt nur die Oberfläche. Kommt aber auch sehr weit weg, was war das jetzt, 7000 Kilometer? 70.000 Kilometer. Das hat ja den Vorteil, das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch die Motivation, dass man quasi mit jedem Instrument mal aus einer ganz anderen Distanz gehen kann, was ja auch insbesondere für dieses Magnetometer wichtig sein wird, weil man dann eben diese Magnet...
Genau, man gewinnt ein dreidimensionales Bild des Ganzen.
Aber wäre es gerade nicht für die Magnetosphäre auch ganz sinnvoll, dass man das vielleicht mal umkippt, dass man mal im Südpol am nächsten ist, weil gerade Nordpol...
Wäre es bestimmt, aber in dem Fall musste man sich entscheiden, was man will.
Das ist ja sozusagen nicht machbar. Man kann jetzt nicht diesen Orbit so eiern lassen, dass man vielleicht über ein Zeitraum von einem Jahr den Punkt woanders hat.
Das wäre im Vergleich zu Venus auch zu gefährlich durch die starke Gravitation von der Sonne. Bei Mars Express zum Beispiel hat man einen Orbit, das ähnlich elliptisch ist, wenn auch nicht ganz so weit rausgeht. Aber da verändert sich der Marsnächste Punkt permanent. Das heißt, der rotiert ganz langsam um den ganzen Planeten.
Und das geht wegen der Sonne nicht bei der Venus?
Ja, weil im Prinzip wäre dieses Problem mit der Gravitation, dass die Höhe sehr stark beeinflusst wird von der Gravitation. Und man hätte wesentlich mehr Probleme oder man müsste wesentlich mehr Sprit aufbringen, um das zu kontrollieren. Und so viel kann man einfach gar nicht mitnehmen, wie man dafür brauchen würde.
Da sind sie wieder die Konsträten.
Die Gesetzmäßigkeiten der Natur.
Ja, interessant. Wie lange hält denn der Sprit?
Noch? Es lässt sich bei Venus Express relativ gut vorhersagen, weil wir relativ viele große Manöver brauchen, um den Orbit zu halten. Im Moment sieht es so aus, als wäre irgendwann 2015 Schluss.
Okay, also in drei Jahren? Dann ist das Ding ja dann aber immerhin zehn Jahre unterwegs gewesen. Ist das auch das, was man am Anfang meinte, wie lange es dauern soll?
Ja, die Laufzeiten sind sehr konservativ ausgelegt. Das heißt, meistens für ein, zwei Jahre. Diese funktionieren müssen, um ein Minimum an Wissenschaftsdaten liefern zu können. Jetzt sind wir bei zehn Jahren, also der hat sehr gut gearbeitet.
Und dann würde er ja einfach runterfallen.
Im Prinzip würde er runterfallen, weil wir den Orbit nicht mehr hochbringen können, weil der Sprit halt alle ist. Und in dem Fall haben wir uns jetzt entschlossen, dass wir zu Ende der Mission Aerobraking machen, mit Venus Express, bis er kaputt ist, oder vielleicht überlebt und noch eine Minimission hinten dran hängt in einem neuen Orbit. Allein um die Atmosphäre noch besser zu skalieren und um Erfahrungen zu sammeln für die ESA allgemein in puncto Aerobraking, was man für spätere Missionen bei anderen Planeten brauchen könnte, um da einen Orbit in einen Orbit anzuschießen.
Das heißt, man weiß ja, der Satellit hat seine Schuldigkeit getan. Richtig. Er würde jetzt im Zweifelsfall sowieso eigentlich nur noch kaputt gehen.
Dann kann man noch Nutzen draus ziehen.
Man kann den Vorgang so kontrollieren und in so definierten und gut überwachten Schritten diesen Vorgang so machen, dass man einfach schaut, wie weit wir denn kommen. Wie verändert sich das? Wie dramatisch ist vor allem dann dieser Eintaucheffekt in diesem Gasozean? Was passiert dann? Was ist eure Erwartung? Wie lange man da noch Daten bekommt? Ist die Erwartung, dass die Atmosphäre den zerreißt? Oder wird er das wahrscheinlich überleben? Und dann liegt er irgendwie auf dem Boden und man empfängt auch noch was?
Es hängt sehr viel Fingerspitzengefühl daran, wie man eintaucht. Wenn man zu leicht eintaucht, da hat man keinen großen Effekt. Und wenn man zu stark eintaucht, dann hat man einen starken Effekt, aber kommt da nicht mehr raus.
Wenn man zu leicht eintaucht?
Wenn man nur ganz wenig oben mitnimmt, dann ist der Effekt der Orbitänderung fast gleich null. Also da merkt man keinen großen Effekt. Wenn man wirklich einen Effekt sehen will, muss man schon ein bisschen tiefer gehen, damit sich das auch bemerkbar macht. Und in dem Fall haben wir noch keine Erfahrungswerte. Es gibt zwar vom Hersteller maximale Faktoren im Punkt der Thermik in der Struktur, wo es ihn irgendwann zerreißen würde. Aber wie genau diese Werte sich jetzt auch ändern oder anpassen in dieser Atmosphäre, die man eigentlich in den tieferen Strukturen gar nicht so genau kennt, das kann man nicht vorhersehen. Das ist ein Erfahrungswert, den man machen muss, wenn man wirklich diese Versuche macht. Und genau deshalb haben wir das auch ans Ende der Mission gelegt, wo wir sozusagen sagen, die Mission ist jetzt vorbei. Die normale Wissenschaftsmission Venus Express ist vorbei. Und ab jetzt nehmen wir Venus Express als Technologieträger sozusagen. Es ist eine völlig neue Mission in dem Fall, die geplant schon damit endet, dass höchstwahrscheinlich Venus Express dann verloren geht. Und solange wir Daten kriegen können von dieser Phase, solange wir die Erfahrungen sammeln können, für später auch, wie sowas funktioniert mit dem Aerobraking, wir werden natürlich versuchen, das so zu machen, dass wir es möglichst lange machen können. Und da müssen wir halt genau rechnen, gucken, wie wir da genau eintauchen, wie wir den Effekt am besten für uns nutzen können.
Das heißt, im Idealfall taucht man so ein, dass man möglichst viel Daten empfängt, dass das Ding möglichst lange hält.
Und gleichzeitig das Orbit noch reduziert von den 24 Stunden auf vielleicht 18 Stunden oder so.
Dass man sich so langsam da in diese Atmosphäre rein drückt. Was ist so dein Gefühl dabei, wie lange der Spaß so gehen kann? Ist das dann innerhalb von 10 Minuten vorbei? Und dann muss noch schnell irgendwie zuhören? Oder ist das auch so ein Vorgang, der Tage oder Wochen in Anspruch nimmt?
Es ist ja so, dadurch, dass wir eine hocheleiptische Bahn haben, ist der Punkt, der am nächsten an der Venus dran ist, gleichzeitig der Punkt, wo der Satellit am schnellsten unterwegs ist. Das heißt, die relative Geschwindigkeit ist maximal. Und deshalb ist das Eintauchen in der Atmosphäre relativ kurz. Dann hat einen relativ starken Effekt, aber nicht für sehr lange. Und das ist auch das, was mit einberechnet wird. Was ist nicht sehr lange? Das sind Minuten, sage ich mal. Das sind 10, 15 Minuten, wo man dann wirklich diesen Effekt hat.
Das sind wieder die 7 Minuten des Terrors.
Da, wo man nichts machen kann und immer hoffen kann, dass er hinterher wieder da auftaucht, wo wir ihn haben. Und dass eine richtige Orbit-Änderung in dem Sinne relativ lange dauert, ist klar.
Also das ist jetzt nichts, was man dann noch groß beobachten kann und wo man dann noch weitere Maßnahmen machen kann. Man muss eigentlich diese Schlussphase nutzen, um sich so richtig Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie machen wir es jetzt genau. Und dann gibt es den Point of No Return, da drückt man auf den Knopf und sagt, okay, jetzt springen wir da mal rein und dann gucken wir mal. Und dann muss das Ding im Prinzip im Idealfall ja noch während des Eintauchens seine Antenne so ausgerichtet haben, dass es nicht zu machen.
Nein, das geht leider nicht, weil die Hauptantenne von Venus Express fest ist. Das heißt, wir können die nicht drehen. Und wir müssen den Satelliten fürs Aerobraking in eine bestimmte Position bringen. Weil während des Aerobrakings auch die Lage des Satelliten nicht mehr mit den Drollrädern, sondern mit den Düsen kontrolliert wird. Und das geht nur im Zusammenhang mit der Fläche, die wir überhaupt gegen die Atmosphäre einsetzen können. Heißt, dass der sozusagen mit dem Hintern nach vorne fliegt, die Düsen kontrollieren die Lage und die Antenne zeigt halt irgendwo da oder da oder dahin, aber nicht da zur Erde.
Das heißt, man kann genau in dem Moment eigentlich gar keine Daten mehr empfangen?
Nein, die werden aufgezeichnet wieder an Bord und nachdem er durch ist, dreht er sich selbstständig wieder zur Erde und funkt die Daten runter.
Nachdem er durch die Atmosphäre ist, das heißt die Hoffnung ist...
Genau, wenn er auf der anderen Seite wieder rauskommt, kann man wieder Kontakt haben.
Das heißt, man geht gar nicht davon aus, dass er dann auf der Oberfläche zerschellt.
Nein, nein, wir hoffen ja, dass wir wirklich diverse Durchgänge machen können.
Ich dachte, es gibt ja jetzt nur diesen einen.
Nein, nein, nein, es macht mehr Sinn, das wesentlich häufiger zu probieren und jeweils anzupassen, wie tief wir reingehen.
Man tastet sich es sozusagen an, nippt sozusagen, also touchiert quasi die Atmosphäre etwas fester, als man das normalerweise macht, und fliegt wieder raus. Und das wird wahrscheinlich auch ein paar Mal funktionieren. Und dann kann man immer tiefer, immer tiefer, bis man so quasi an so einem Punkt ist, wo man dann wirklich nicht mehr rauskommt. Das muss man dann aber dann sozusagen auch rechtzeitig vor dem eigentlichen theoretischen Ende machen, damit man für diese ganzen Späße auch noch genug Power hat.
Es wäre schön, dass das so zu machen ist, dass wir wissen, erst im nächsten Orbit gehen wir ganz runter. Dann können wir die Daten von dem letzten, bevor er runtergegangen ist, noch auswerten.
Und wie viele Versuche erträumt man sich da so?
Das ist unklar. Der Traum der Wissenschaftler in dem Fall ist natürlich, dass wir das Orbit runterfahren können, vom 24-Stunden-Orbit auf einen 18-Stunden-Orbit. Und dann immer noch sozusagen funktionieren. Und die sozusagen aus dieser neuen Position andere wissenschaftliche Beobachtungen machen können. Dadurch, dass sie im fernsten Punkt näher dran sind auf einmal. Und im nächsten Punkt vielleicht ein bisschen höher. Weil dadurch, dass die Geschwindigkeit abnimmt beim Error-Breaking, wird sozusagen der erdfernste runtergedrückt. Und die Geschwindigkeit am nächsten Punkt ist geringer. Das heißt, da rutscht da noch ein bisschen Haut. Das kann man dann wieder besser kontrollieren.
Das heißt, wenn man damit einmal mal angefangen hat, kann man auch nicht mehr aufhören.
Nein, auch deshalb machen wir es ja am Ende der Mission. Weil wir genau wissen, dass es passieren kann, dass wir irgendwann nicht mehr rauskommen.
Aber wenn man einmal rauskommt, taucht man beim nächsten Mal auf jeden Fall auch wieder so ein.
Solange man allerdings noch Sprit zur Verfügung hat, kann man das dann leicht wieder anpassen, wo man eintaucht. Das ist halt so die Frage, wie viel Sprit haben wir am Ende noch übrig, um diese Kontrolle zu haben.
Das heißt, man zieht das Ende dann auch nicht wirklich auf den letzten möglichen Tag, sondern man versucht schon noch mit einer gewissen Reserve da ranzugehen.
Man geht schon mit dem Plan wirklich, dieses Aerobraking so zu benutzen, dass wir das Orbit ändern. Das ist schon, es soll mal so ausprobiert werden. Wenn das dabei halt dann zu Bruch geht sozusagen, dann ist das halt so.
Das ist so ein bisschen das interstellare Flitzesteinchen, was man so über den See schmeißt. Man hofft, dass man einfach möglichst viele kleine Hüpfer erzeugen kann und irgendwann wird es dann einfach komplett eintauchen.
Das ist eine ganz spannende Sache halt auch für uns, diese Kontrolle dann durchzuführen, weil das was ist, was in der ESA noch keiner gemacht hat.
Das kann ja auch wirklich mehrere, kann ja eine schlaflose Woche werden. Weil man hat ja dann eigentlich...
Vielleicht Monate?
Dauerersatz.
Wer weiß.
Spannend. Das ist dann 2015, in drei Jahren.
In drei Jahren sind wir so weit. Dann wird irgendwann gesagt, das war es jetzt und jetzt versuchen wir es mal. Wow. Das wird eine spannende Sache.
Ja, das war jetzt hier auch eine spannende Sache, Jörg. Jetzt haben wir es hier ganz gut eingetütet. Venus Express, der Flug da zu dem dampfenden Planeten. Kann schon vorwegnehmen. Als nächstes werden wir uns natürlich den Planeten nochmal selber vornehmen, wie das hier bei unserer kleinen Sonnensystem-Tour so üblich ist. Aber ich bedanke mich jetzt schon mal hier für die Ausführung.
Oh, bitteschön. Es war sehr unterhaltsam.
Ja, auf jeden Fall und auch sehr lehrreich. Und ich bin schon ganz gespannt, wie das wird da mit dem intergalaktischen...
Wir werden euch informieren.
Alles klar, super. Gut, vielen Dank, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war's, Raumzeit, bald geht's weiter.